[Music]
I'm distracted by this gentleman in
these shorts right here
[Applause]
today are I yes by but you're definitely
not a male model there's no guy
check out that Catholics Oscar
nominations were announced this morning
isn't that exciting very exciting the
movie Lincoln received 12 Oscar
nominations you know what that means
sequel Lincoln to the Lincoln age yeah
Lincoln to Breaking Dawn weekend at age
hit weekend today beeps in 3d ah a lot
of exciting news this year did you hear
this a nine-year-old girl was nominated
for an Oscar making her the youngest
nominee ever yeah she says she's dreamed
of winning an Oscar ever since last week
President Obama's inauguration coming up
just a couple days away now during next
week's inauguration President Obama they
just announced will be sworn in with not
one but two Bibles he's warning with two
Bibles I just want to take a second to
say just relax mr. president we get it
you're not a Muslim okay
you're overcompensating two Bibles and
I'll dress as a priest yeah and Michels
dressing as a Bible survival's it's been
reported that tickets to President
Obama's inauguration are being scalped
on Craigslist for $2,000 on Craigslist
yeah for interested send an email to
vice pres du b at gmail he hosan wants
to sell a futon
I couldn't believe this Justin Bieber's
in the news Justin Bieber's being sued
for allegedly beating up his ex
bodyguard
yes which begs the question who hires a
bodyguard that Justin Bieber can beat
insanity
[Applause]
yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
hit me
sanity muscles going on New Jersey
Governor Chris Christie is on the cover
of Time magazine yeah well some of him
is it's hard to get all of them in hair
we're also going on hey and also in
politics the mayor of Washington DC says
he wants the Washington Redskins to
change their name to something less
offensive yeah so they are changing it
to the Maryland Redskins
oh yeah I see what coming dude yeah
adhere this some McDonald's are now
replacing the toy that comes in a happy
meal with a book yeah yeah the the title
of the book is being a kid in 2013 blows
this is weird as a new trend of pregnant
women trying to induce labor by having
sex in the delivery room yes in a
related story there's a new trend of
babies being born and saying good god
what the hell was that
[Applause]
hey never want to see that again in my
life
got to mention this last thing this
story came out early this week but I
have to repeat because it's so weird the
University of Arizona now offers a
degree in hip-hop now trust me that's
one class where you don't want to cheat
off the Asian kid
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]